Hallo zusammen,
herzlich willkommen zum "Q&A"
zu unserem Film "FIFA schickt
Fussball-WM 2022 in die Wüste -
Katars Kampf für ein modernes Image".
Wir haben ziemlich viele Fragen
und Reaktionen zum Film erhalten.
Christoph Muggler,
der Produzent des Films,
und ich werden nun
einige davon etwas genauer anschauen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ein Stichwort,
das immer wieder fällt, ist Boykott.
Ich werde immer wieder
darauf angesprochen,
ob man diese WM
boykottieren soll oder nicht.
Ich persönlich finde,
es gibt gute Gründe,
gigantische Anlässe
wie eine WM zu boykottieren.
Ist es z.B. aus ökologischen Gründen
noch zeitgemäss,
dass Stadien gebaut werden, dass
Fans aus der ganzen Welt anreisen?
Aber ich finde,
es gibt keinen spezifischen Grund,
diese WM in Katar zu boykottieren.
Man muss sich fragen:
Warum speziell diese WM?
Man kann sagen, sie wurde gekauft,
das war Korruption,
aber seit 1994
wurde vermutlich jede WM gekauft.
Bei manchen weiss man es genauer,
bei anderen weniger.
Dann kann man sagen, wegen der
Menschenrechtssituation in Katar.
Ja, die ist nicht zufriedenstellend,
sie genügt unseren Standards nicht.
Aber die Menschenrechtsorganisation
Amnesty International sagt z.B.,
dass es wohl
die einzige WM ever sei,
die positive Auswirkungen
haben könnte -
eben gerade, weil in diesem
Bereich viel erreicht werden konnte.
Dazu kommt die Frage:
Wie viel bringt zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt überhaupt noch ein Boykott?
Die Fernsehrechte sind verkauft,
die Stadien gebaut.
Darum gefällt mir der Ansatz,
den z.B. die Gewerkschaften haben.
Sie stützen
Amnesty International und sagen:
"Wir nutzen die Aufmerksamkeit
rund um die prekären Bedingungen,
unter denen diese WM
organsiert wurde,
um etwas zu verbessern."
Es stellt sich eine
grundsätzliche Frage, wenn man sagt,
dass die Menschen in Katar,
im arabischen Raum,
nach Werten handeln,
die nicht die unseren sind,
und man deshalb
nichts damit zu tun haben will.
Da muss man sich bewusst sein,
dass unsere Wirtschaft
sehr eng
mit der katarischen verknüpft ist.
Habeck z.B. reist nach Katar,
um Energiesicherheiten herzustellen.
Auch sonst ist Katar sehr eng
mit unserer Wirtschaft verflochten
und auch mit unserem Fussball.
Der wichtigste Mann
im europäischen Fussball
ist der Präsident von PSG mit
dem wohl wichtigsten Amt der UEFA.
Er stammt aus Katar
und ist ein Jugendfreund des Emirs.
Deswegen boykottiert wohl
niemand die Champions League.
Man muss sich einfach bewusst sein,
dass wir sehr eng verflochten sind.
Will man das boykottieren,
dann muss man alles,
was damit zusammenhängt,
boykottieren.
Also entweder sagen,
dass man konsequent den gesamten
arabischen Raum boykottiert,
oder aber schauen,
dass wir wenigstens mit unseren
Mitteln Gutes bewirken können.
Gut, machen wir weiter.
- Wir machen weiter.
Was haben wir noch?
Genau: Eine Szene des Films
gab viel zu reden,
und zwar diejenige ganz am Schluss,
als wir
mit Bauinspektor Robert Schwitter
und Rita Schiavi
auf der Baustelle waren.
Der Bauinspektor sorgte ziemlich
für Furore in den Kommentarspalten.
Christian z.B. schrieb:
Christoph, du hast einen ganzen Stick
solcher Bilder erhalten.
Es gibt ganz viele Bilder,
nicht nur die gezeigten. - Genau.
Im Film zeigten wir
nur eine Auswahl an Bildern,
diejenigen,
die wir am passendsten fanden.
Aber er gab mir
Tausende bzw. Hunderte Fotos,
die die Zustände vor Ort zeigen,
und für mich gibt es keinen Grund,
an deren Glaubwürdigkeit
zu zweifeln.
Auch nicht an derjenigen
von Herrn Schwitter,
er ist ausgewiesener Experte
in genau diesem Bereich.
Er konnte die Situation
auf den Stadionbaustellen in Katar
genau einschätzen und beobachten.
Ehrlich gesagt
kann ich die entstandene Irritation
und Verwirrung nachvollziehen,
denn mir ging es auch so.
Ich war im Gespräch etwas irritiert,
denn ich erwartete, dass der Mann
von den prekären Unterkünften,
von den Missständen
auf den Baustellen erzählen würde -
so, wie man das im Fernsehen
bis dato mitgekriegt hatte.
Ich war dann
schon überrascht und irritiert,
dass er mir ein Bild zeichnete,
das ich so nicht erwartet hätte,
ein Bild von fortschrittlichen,
neumodischen Baustellen,
die in Topzustand
und auf dem neuesten Stand sind.
Aber im Gespräch
erklärte sich das Ganze für mich.
Er sagte selbst,
dass sie erst ab 2017
die Stadionbaustellen
inspizieren konnten.
Zudem waren diese Inspektionen,
was nicht unüblich ist, angekündigt.
Man wusste also, dass jemand kommt.
Die Baustellen waren ab 2014 ...
- 2014, 2015.
Damals begann man
mit den Bauarbeiten in Katar.
Man hatte bis zu den Inspektionen
also ordentlich Zeit,
um die ganze Situation vor Ort
anzupassen
und um auf die internationale Kritik
zu reagieren.
Das wurde offenbar gemacht.
Mit dieser Erklärung fand ich
nachvollziehbar, was er sagte.
Und wirklich niemand
widerspricht seinen Aussagen.
Die Gewerkschaften
sagen dasselbe wie er.
Und auch Amnesty sagt,
dass es auf den Stadionbaustellen
ab 2017 keine Probleme mehr gab.
Es ging dann v.a.
um andere Baustellen in Katar,
was natürlich
nicht weniger schlimm ist
und was
den viel grösseren Teil ausmacht.
Auf den Stadionbaustellen arbeiteten
ca. 0,5 % der Gastarbeiter in Katar.
Das Problem lag
nicht bei den Stadionbaustellen,
zumindest nicht ab 2017.
Und wir haben noch
andere Quotes von Herrn Schwitter,
in denen er das Ganze
etwas besser belegen kann.
Es wurde nicht einfach so gemacht.
Es funktioniert nicht,
wenn man es nur kurz hintun wollte.
Man würde sofort sehen,
wenn es nur Schauspiel wäre.
Schon nur, wie sie
die Sachen in die Hände nehmen ...
Oder auf den Gerüsten sind sie
durch Absturzsicherungen gesichert -
überall mit zwei Karabinerhaken.
Ich schaute auch, ob diese Haken
glatt wie ein Babyhintern sind
oder ob sie wirklich benutzt werden.
Und es wird wirklich gelebt.
Aufgrund
meiner Berufserfahrung als Polier
und später
als Baustellenkontrolleur
habe ich natürlich
zig Jahre Erfahrung.
Sie können mir keine Kartoffeln als
Äpfel verkaufen - oder umgekehrt.
Dann hat jemand geschrieben:
Voll, absolut legitim.
- Fairer Punkt.
Katar hat eine Chance erhalten
und diese teils genutzt.
Die Frage ist: Wie geht es
mit diesen Verbesserungen weiter?
Haben diese
einen langfristigen Nutzen?
"Fussball soll verbinden."
Das ist auch ein spannender Aspekt:
Es wird gesagt, dass Katar
keine Fussballtradition habe.
Manche fragen sich, weshalb
dort eine WM stattfinden soll.
Die nächste Fussball-WM findet
in den USA statt - wie schon 1994.
Aber gibt es dort
eine Fussballtradition?
Was oft vergessen wird:
Im arabischen Raum gibt es
unglaublich viele Fussballfans:
in Katar, in Saudi-Arabien,
im Iran, in Ägypten.
Diese Menschen
schauen Premier League, La Liga usw.
Wenn Mo Salah spielt,
dann schauen alle zu.
Zumindest eine Fussball-
fankultur gibt es dort sehr wohl.
Und die Menschen, die sich dort
für Fussball interessieren,
freuen sich riesig auf die WM.
In diesem Sinn wird
der arabische Raum nun inkludiert,
global gesehen verbindet Fussball
also, könnte man sagen.
Michi hat Folgendes geschrieben:
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Wir haben im Film klar aufgezeigt,
dass Katar nicht einfach
nur diese Fussball-WM organisiert,
sondern dass es
einen Sport-Masterplan gibt.
Eine Offensive.
Seit diesem Tennisturnier 1993
bringen sie
einen Sportanlass nach dem anderen.
Und ja, man kann sich fragen:
Hätte man nicht jede WM
so kritisch betrachten müssen?
Für viele wurden Stadien
und sonstige Infrastruktur gebaut.
Bei der Leichtathletik-WM
gab es das Thema Hitze.
Der Marathon wurde
mitten in der Nacht gelaufen,
damit es einigermassen ging und weil
viele Sportler/-innen kollabierten.
Aber ja,
ein absolut legitimer Punkt.
Ich möchte hinzufügen:
Es ist wohl auch einfach
der Macht des Fussballs geschuldet.
Es ist halt eine Sportart,
die weltweit sehr viele Fans hat
und stark bewegt.
Entsprechend zieht der Fussball
sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit auf sich.
Es ist ein Interesse vorhanden,
das dazu führt, dass die inter-
nationale Aufmerksamkeit grösser ist
als bei anderen Sportarten -
das spielt sicher mit rein.
Es ist völlig legitim, zu sagen,
dass man bei jeder Weltmeisterschaft
kritisch hinschauen kann und muss.
Zum Schluss
ist vielleicht noch spannend,
was wir beide mitnehmen konnten
vom Projekt, von der Dok,
von den Recherchen.
Was ist dir geblieben?
Als ich das Projekt startete,
hatte ich schon auch die Haltung,
dass das Ganze
verwerflich und schlimm ist.
Mein Blick auf die WM, auf Katar
ist viel differenzierter geworden -
auch auf die FIFA,
die sich ja auch verändert hat.
Für mich
wurde bei vielem nachvollziehbar,
weshalb gewisse Dinge
so passiert sind.
Spannend ist z.B. auch
die Perspektive von Katar.
Warum wollen sie das?
In unserem Film hatte das vielleicht
nicht so ein Gewicht,
aber es gibt auch
den Sicherheitsaspekt.
Katar fühlt sich bedroht
von Saudi-Arabien und Iran,
zwei riesigen Mächten.
Katar kann sich dagegen
nicht militärisch wehren,
sondern nur durch Aufmerksamkeit -
dafür sind Sportanlässe ein Mittel.
Man kann die Situation
mit Kuwait vergleichen,
das Anfang 90er-Jahre
vom Irak überfallen wurde.
Ebenfalls ein kleines Emirat,
das von einer Grossmacht
militärisch angegriffen wurde
und eigentlich machtlos war.
Das hat sich stark in das
katarische Gedächtnis eingebrannt
und ist ebenfalls ein Treiber
dieser Aufmerksamkeitsstrategie.
Mir ist ein anderer Aspekt
stark geblieben -
nämlich derjenige der Korruption.
Meines Erachtens
wurde es lange so dargestellt,
dass dies wahnsinnig
spezifisch für Katar sei,
dass sich Katar
mit korrupten Machenschaften,
mit Bestechungsgeldern
die WM gekauft habe.
In unserer Dok,
während unseren Recherchen
und z.B. auch im Interview
mit Bonita Mersiades,
der australischen Whistleblowerin,
wurde aber klar:
Katar ist kein Sonderfall.
Wenn man das Spiel spielen
und mitmachen wollte,
wenn man die WM
für sein Land holen wollte,
dann musste man
nach den Regeln der FIFA spielen.
Wenn man also
mit dem Finger auf Katar zeigt,
dann muss man mit dem Finger
auch auf den Zürichberg zeigen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Florian Schuler - 2022